yeah hello scalebound is the biggest
game we've ever made at Platinum Games
an action RPG where you can freely
freely explore a vast mysterious world
on foot or on the back of a most
majestic dragon you play as the young
man from Earth named drew who along with
the dragon Toobin have been searching
for a powerful artifact to succeed
they'll need to fight through the
soldiers of an evil empire and even more
dangerous foes I'm excited to show you
scalebound gameplay for the very first
time welcome to the world of Draconis
it's almost time to rejoin the main unit
that's right the carrier ship will
arrive in about an hour
good
me for gradually can you see sport then
that I expected you're up big guy that
was that for
I give up if you ask me to use your
words punish - oh man here we go no yeah
well maybe you should i bind me
all right
let's head that way
Frances musta hurt you thrashed
let's dump this guy
history
come on let's get out of here before any
of his friends show up
holy [ __ ]
it seems like a fair fight just one of
you against all of us
ladies and gentlemen head of platform
engineering Mikey bar